I'm absolutely here for the
Grimace-shakes-will-kill you-trend but,
So. Many. Questions. Starting with; Is Grimace
a monster? Yes, Grimace is most definitely a
monster. When he was introduced in 1971, he
had four arms looked kind of scaly and stole
milkshakes from children - which is terrifying
and rude. McDonald's realized pretty quickly
driving kids away was not good for business and
Grimace was made over into the amorphous purple
blob we know and love today. Grimace lore says
he might be shaped to look like a taste bud,
weird, though the official stand is that he's the
embodiment of a milkshake. Which is just as weird.
Could this original evil Grimace incarnation be
behind the deadly milkshake trend? The best I can
figure is that Grimace is a byproduct of the
1970s and some corporate branding practices,
and this month the internet made him
their own by injecting some horror back
into Ronald's best friend. Another win for
modern pop culture monsters and capitalism.